all right how's everybody doing
we are um continuing to count ballots we
have
updates we do not yet have a call
although it's conceivable that in the
next 45 minutes or so
something will happen but my guess is
still
probably not so welcome i'm glad
everybody
is here we have a lot to discuss we're
going to look at
nevada we're going to look at arizona
has become a subject we're going to look
at videos i'm going to hear from
from some of you guys hopefully as well
um and there's just
a lot a lot a lot to discuss
where to even start i mean i guess i
guess at this point where we should
start
is what's going on officially so we
still have joe biden at 264 electoral
votes donald trump at 214
now for my purposes i'm giving trump 217
because i'm just giving trump alaska now
i know that there are actually some
people saying
hey if you look at alaska they've been
stuck at 50
reporting it's not completely
inconceivable that biden could get it
i just don't think this this race is
going to um
depend on alaska uh and i can maybe
explain the math of that a little bit
later but i think alaska
is done arizona is a question only
because not every network has called it
now i'm gonna get protest video for you
momentarily
there's protests to count votes and
there's also protests
not to count votes going on right now
and then there's also just people
praying
uh invoking i guess demonic destruction
in order to win
by trump so everything everything is
happening right now i'm going to get to
some of that video in a little bit
but i'm pretty confident about arizona
the associated press data which is this
right here
has been really conservative and fox
news
there's actually something going on with
fox news where it seems as though rupert
murdoch
is interested in being the first to call
this for biden
they are confident chris wallace says
that
arizona is going for for joe biden
so i think that arizona will go biden
and i i see there's a few people in my
chat
saying no no no no i think arizona is
going biden and so given that where we
are right now
is that any one state gives this
presidential race to joe biden if joe
biden gets nevada he gets to 270.
uh hold on if uh joe biden gets pen
we'll look at each state if joe biden
gets pennsylvania he gets the 284
if joe biden gets north carolina he gets
the 279
and if joe biden gets georgia he gets
280. now for me the most likely is
nevada why because he's currently
winning in nevada
uh in nevada i don't really i don't
really understand what's going on in
nevada
they resumed counting earlier today and
all day we've only gotten one percent of
the vote
now that one percent did push joe
biden's lead from 0.7 to 0.9
but word is that nevada is done for the
day they're gonna continue counting
tomorrow i
i just don't understand what's happening
in nevada why they're counting so slowly
but
that is the most direct path now
understand that if biden gets nevada
understand the importance of the
nebraska second district because
if biden gets nevada and nothing else
without the second district in nebraska
biden's at 269.
if biden gets that second district in
nebraska which he did
that gets him to 270. now people are
asking me about the ralston report tweet
about uh nevada um
i don't have the i saw it i don't have
that
but i do have this tweet from emma
kinnery which is
from uh about ten minutes ago five
minutes ten minutes ago nevada's
secretary of state says there are
approximately 190
000 ballots to count 90 of which are
from heavily democratic clark county
the importance of it being clark county
is clark county is where uh where las
vegas is
uh biden is running plus eight there so
if 90 of the ballots are from clark
county
and joseph r biden jr is running eight
points ahead
you all understand that that would very
much imply a joe biden win
in nevada that is the relevance of this
tweet
okay so we got that what else do we have
i have a lot of different things so
anyway right now nevada is not there
let's now look at state by state
what is going on so i already told you
and i'll tell you the changes from
yesterday
nevada has gone from a biden plus
0.7 to biden plus
0.9 okay so slightly improving
in nevada for joe biden in pennsylvania
you might remember yesterday when i was
streaming
we started with a lead of like 6.9 for
trump it went to 6.56 5.9 5.5 and it was
declining
um joe biden is now only down by 1.5
in pennsylvania that is very very close
and if we look at the trajectory you can
actually see here
trump's biggest lead was right around
the 37
mark when 37 of the vote had been
counted
and then it went down then it went back
up a little bit but since then
the vote in pennsylvania has been
getting better and better and better
for joe biden similarly in
uh georgia it is now only 0.2 percent
separating the two candidates
okay it is 13 no it's point twelve
thousand eight hundred votes
doing some rough math separating the two
candidates and
in georgia very similar thing
me the biggest lead for trump was here
right around the 34
35 tallied mark and it has been
tightening ever since
and conceivably that could reverse
and then in nevada we saw a little bit
of a different situation where
biden took a slightly larger lead and
the lead has tightened titan titan to
where we are now
now with 90 of the vote remaining being
from clark county which houses las vegas
one would assume that the the lead would
hold for joe biden
but we don't yet know we don't yet know
so all we can do is wait at this point
in time
now in the meantime donald trump has
started filing
uh lawsuits uh he started filing i don't
even think he knows really who he's
suing or for what but
they are alleging lawsuits in michigan
um they are alleging lawsuits in where
else
michigan i think in wisconsin they want
to recount
lawsuit in pennsylvania lawsuit in
georgia
they're suing anybody they can so that's
interesting last thing
see here how purdue versus assaf purdue
is at 50
this is very relevant because if purdue
were to drop below 50
uh that would trigger a runoff in
georgia it's a three-way race in georgia
and if no candidate gets a majority then
um
they then there would be a runoff
involving john ossoff and david perdue
which would just extend the possibility
there i don't know that it means john
ossoff wins
but that is going to be very very
interesting
i'm being told via a very strong twitch
message that
george's remaining votes aren't going to
be counted until
saturday or or i don't know if they're
saying on saturday or by saturday but in
any case we're waiting for that
so that's very important to bear in mind
as well
okay i have a ton of other stuff to go
over
as we continue to so people asking what
is a runoff
so you've got three candidates in that
race a runoff would be
a subsequent a special election with
just the top two vote getters
and in certain situations if no
candidate gets 50
the top two vote getters everybody else
is out the top two vote getters sort of
have like their own
new election and um oh people asking why
i'm not even talking about north
carolina
i don't think north carolina is where
joe biden is going to get over 50
over 270 electoral votes i don't think
biden gets
north carolina and by the way for some
reason i just don't know
uh it's been 24 hours since the last
updates in north carolina there's just
no maybe even 30 35 hours
in north i don't know what's happening
in north carolina i've not gotten a
clear answer
couldn't tell you but i am not counting
on north carolina to be
what brings uh joe biden to victory at
this point in time
so i'm people are telling me that the
vote count won't be updated at all
in north carolina until the 12th i
thought that it was
they have until the 12th but some people
are telling me there will be no update
until the 12th
okay well let's wait and see i want to
say thanks to makana garcia
as well as jack watson and heather
strzeck i'm having trouble saying that
a new members number one two and three
on my website today i appreciate that
thanks for signing up at joinpakman.com
let me also just set a starting point
for us as far as twitch goes
it looks like seven people have signed
up
on twitch and that puts us at 1959 just
to get us a baseline because i don't
want to i don't want to lose track
things get crazy and i don't know what's
going on
okay let me get to a few super chats
just to see what's on people's minds
parikh ravi says that on the georgia
secretary of state website purdue is
already below 50
at 49.99 okay yeah
let's see when when things go final
we'll get a sense of what's going on
there
barry says the west coast of canada is
rooting for biden
juicy bacon says if the election result
is decided by amy coney barrett
after it's been called for joe biden we
will see insane mass protests i agree
with you
um jose
asks what happens if biden wins nevada
and nothing else then no one will have
270.
no if biden wins nevada he gets 270. uh
again i
i believe ap and fox news on arizona
um so if biden wins nevada that is 270
and joseph r biden jr becomes the
president-elect
hasn't been called yet hasn't been
called yet but i do
uh that i am very very uh i feel
confident about the arizona call
now let you guys want to see some wacky
stuff
let's get to some wet just wacky video
let's see where we oh first of all
before we get to wacky video
i don't know if you guys have been
following donald trump's twitter he is
just having a complete and total
meltdown
he's retweeting eric trump's request to
stop they would say pennsylvania
michigan nevada georgia and wisconsin
they're claiming fraud
um almost all of trump's tweets are
misleading and they've been flagged by
twitch
it's it's i'm sorry by twitter they
should be flagged on twitch anyway
they've been flagged by twitter trump's
saying stop the fraud
of course there's no evidence oh hold on
a second there's no actual evidence of
fraud at this point in time
another one from trump all of the recent
biden claims states will be legally
challenged by us
for voter fraud and state election fraud
plenty of proof check out the media
wait so now the media tells us the truth
trump's been campaigning against the
fake news
phony fake media for four years now he
says just look at the media they'll tell
you about all the fraud so there is a
very strong warning on that
trump uh says he had a big legal win in
pennsylvania i believe that was then
reversed and thrown out by the
pennsylvania supreme court so that's in
the trash
trump demanding that the count be
stopped
um guys you can't let the vote counting
get in the way of the election which is
basically counting votes
the the vote counting is getting in the
way of counting votes
and speaking of which i've uh hold on
where are my tweets
um let's see the con
so the contrast between trump and biden
right now trump i've already won
vote counts must stop in pennsylvania
and michigan recount wisconsin and i'm
filing seven lawsuits against fraudulent
democratic states
biden came out yesterday and said votes
are still being counted i believe i have
a path to 270
and if i do win we're going to reduce
the temperature and i will be
everybody's president so a pretty
dramatic contrast right now between the
two candidates
according to republicans this is how you
run the election fairly
you have to keep counting in arizona you
have to count more slowly in georgia
you have to stop counting pennsylvania
and michigan
you have to recount wisconsin and every
time there's a vote dump
as trump calls them that are heavily
biden those definitely be need to be
thrown out
uh what else and yes as i said counting
votes is a fraudulent diversion
from the primary function of elections
which is to count votes so i i've been
tweeting up a storm today i hope you
guys are following me
there and then big news just minutes ago
nbc is reporter
reporting that mark esper trump's
secretary of defense
has prepared a letter of resignation so
it's starting to get really really
interesting
um and and we're going to continue
covering that and
i have a lot of interesting videos to
play for you guys very very soon
okay what else do we have going on other
super chats
all chad says fox news will soon call
pennsylvania for biden can is that i
have no idea if that's true
nate silver said nevada should be called
for biden
um i don't i don't know if that's true
guys if someone wants to
confirm that i would be fine to pull up
fox news
you've read it on twitter uh okay let me
see if i can find some
fox news live fox
news live and i'll i'll put the screen
back on momentarily i just don't want to
accidentally
like dox myself or anything like that
let's see on
air now kavuto is on again
let's take a look at what's going on
there um
let's see wondering why the stock market
was advancing today as it was yesterday
as it was the day before that as it was
the day before that
oh this should be interesting in the
face of all of this tumult and confusion
in fact even more so uh now post
election day and all the new
confusion why is that why are we now
looking with one day to go on
for the markets since back uh in april
after one of the worst weeks for the
market since
back in march john bussey the wall
street journal associate editor with us
heather zumarraga
uh zuma uh global president heather
what's going on it's got to be a
disconnect or is there a connect
right all the despite all the election
uncertainty the stock market is still
heading
a lot higher now because a few things
mainly because there's no blue wave
right the senate
is is going to i totally disagree with
that guys
just look at the data just look at the
data stocks do better when democrats are
president
job creation's higher when democrats are
president gdp growth is higher when
democrats are president
uh inflation is lower when democrats are
president
you know come on guys these explanations
are just pathetic yeah i think that the
mind virus has spread
uh to fox news as you all know all right
we will oh they're gonna do another
press conference in philadelphia
okay let's do that then this we watch
this live if you guys were on stream
yesterday with me we watch this live
this is performance art what i'm going
to play for you guys
yesterday rudy giuliani was in
philadelphia
with manila envelopes claiming
he's filing four lawsuits that he
doesn't know
that um biden didn't vote 5 000 times
and as he was delivering this rant fox
cut in
to say biden has just won michigan it
was an incredible
whoever wins the the comedic timing of
rudy giuliani
and fox news it has to be seen to be
appreciated let's take a look at any one
of these mail ballots
they could be from mars as far as we're
concerned or they could be from the
democratic national committee
joe biden could have voted 50 times as
far as we know or 5 000 times you have
to wait for it the ballots could be from
camden
philadelphia unfortunately and would say
this about my own city has a reputation
for voter fraud
you have a reputation for dead people
voting right we're going to go look at
just how many dead people voted here
i didn't think we'd have to do that but
we will and you have a reputation for
people being bussed in from camden
voting here
wouldn't be the first time that happened
but this goes way beyond
any of that right and let me also add
this is the best this isn't happening
just here we have exactly the same
lawsuit in wisconsin
where exactly the same thing happened
except in wisconsin mysteriously at four
o'clock
or three o'clock in the morning so now
rudy gets confused 120 000
doesn't know what he's talking about oh
here come these ballads
well we have no idea if they really are
balanced
we have no this is completely understand
this is completely unfalsifiable
it's like by this logic you also don't
know if idaho's ballots are real ballots
right but but there's no reason to think
that they're not they're signed
if they're postmarked properly bose mark
if it isn't just the same person who
submitted
a hundred thousand ballots right one
person hundred they all got counted
this is the way they intend to win all
right brace yourself now i'm informed by
former congressman sweeney who's been we
are continuing
giuliani you might have noticed
something happened to
the electoral vote count for joe biden
our decision desk
has taken a look at michigan and
concluded joe biden has won
michigan and gets the 16 electoral votes
from michigan that puts him now six
electoral votes
from the presidency of the united states
nevada could do it
those electoral votes are still out
there it's just perfect no there's six
electoral votes there if he were to take
that state
he would be at 270 right and he would be
on his way to the white house
now back to the now watch rudy with his
manila there it is
as we speak by team trump
you make sure that it's properly
postmarked
it's the the comedic timing is just
perfect they go back and he's
mid-sentence with the same nonsense
except he's taken out a manila folder at
this point so that's really great stuff
glad to review that with you guys we are
standing by again
for a trump campaign press conference in
philadelphia it might be rudy again
there are trump flags and you know a lot
of people who are
i guess feel very strongly that that
either something is being done wrong
because votes aren't being counted
or something is being done wrong because
votes
are being counted there there's there's
both going on right now
um if you're just joining us we've been
reviewing all of the latest numbers and
data
um at this point in time any one state
that joe biden
can win would clinch the presidency for
him
there are rumors starting that fox news
may be first
to if there is a joe biden call make
that call we're keeping an eye on fox
news pennsylvania now is uh down to a
1.4
lead for donald trump this is the
smallest lead
that we've had since election day
georgia is down to 0.2 percent and the
nevada lead has pushed from 0.7
up to 0.9 um
some amazing numbers some amazing
numbers here as we are standing by
for a trump team press conference uh
in in philadelphia and we have no idea
what it is that they're going to talk
about
okay uh oh what's going on here let's
see
okay nothing yet we're gonna keep a
close eye on that
um i i again am seeing that people are
questioning
the arizona call i i don't on none of
i don't pretend to have any special
knowledge on any of this stuff
all i know is arizona was called by the
associated press
the associated press has been perfect
in their handling of this election so
far they have been very conservative
so on the associated presses say so at
all i believe arizona
fox news also said that they are
completely confident in arizona
as well i believe arizona is is
is going to be blue at this point i i am
fine with arizona uh considered blue so
that's my view on it and again i'm not
pretending to know anything
special i'm just going by what they have
said okay
um so we we are standing by here for
this trump
trump press conference okay a couple of
other things i do see super chats coming
in
um so this is something i want to
mention hat mumfree says check out mark
levin tweeting about electors
mark levin is the oh it's cool oh god
it's lewandowski
oh my god it's lewandowski lewandowski
is completely unhinged i don't know if
you guys saw this
earlier hold on let me find the video
where is the lewandowski video check
this out this is what we're about to get
more of
what is going on in this city what are
you hiding
open up the doors let us in let us six
feet away
so that we can have a free and fair
election okay so lewandowski
is about to lose his mind let's see from
the lawsuit
it says the county board of elections is
aware of okay so we're standing by we're
gonna hear we're gonna hear about that
uh i would get the kids out of the room
um this is probably
not safe for logic oh and is that pam
bondi it is let's see count ballots
without any observation by any
representing
president trump and the republican party
the county board of elections
is intentionally violating the state law
but we have the photograph
uh taken by a republican poll watcher
this is about to be insane watching
the process although he said he is not a
close enough
uh neil back to you all right thank you
eric sean for that i'll pan by the
encore
i seem to be ready to speak right now
let's go to what's been happening
they have refused to let us have
meaningful a meaningful view
of the vote count they have continued to
count the votes
because because they have done nothing
to help us
they are not letting every legal vote
count they are letting anything come in
they are not letting us look at anything
at all nothing so we have filed in
federal
court we've just bought a motion it's
chaos
immediate injunctive relief to shut down
the voting process
shut it down until until
we can get a resolution where we can
look at these ballots there is a reason
that they are suppressing the election
results the legal
election results because they will not
let us look at the ballot
whether you're a democrat or a
republican you should care about this
they're trying to suppress our voices
now and they will not
do it so we have filed in federal court
for immediate
a skit guys
listen guys it's very simple here a
judge in this state
issued a ruling that the board of
elections has summarily dismissed
no the supreme court dismissed it state
supreme court dismissed because they
would not
follow the law of the state of
pennsylvania we have filed for
federal relief that is what we're doing
because we
will not let the people of pennsylvania
go
without having an election observer for
every single battle
[Applause]
it is shameful it is shameful
that the boards of
bothered to stop chewing gum for this
inside to review this process
and the board of elections and your
sheriff said no
sheriff so what do we do we go get
relief
by the federal government to make sure
every legal vote is counted
thank you very much
wow what a moment for democracy huh
we believe every legal vote should be
counted and we have the right to look at
those boats and we're going to make sure
every single vote is permanent seems
high as a kite
thank you guys
it's complete and total mass history oh
let's hear their commentary
it's five o'clock in new york city and
this is the five
[Music]
you know i'm actually i'm actually i'm
finding myself not even caring
it's complete and total mass hysteria
going on
oh i had a couple of other streams going
hold on let me get them for you so this
is abc news
i also wanted nbc and
i would actually maybe maybe that's good
um
we've got the two the two feeds going on
what a complete
and total mess i'm told there's an
update in pennsylvania
uh although i'm not seeing it here let
me see i'm still seeing a 1.4
margin in pennsylvania someone told me
it was 0.2
um wow georgia is down to only a 9 500
vote margin that is incredible
and still nothing new out of
pennsylvania still a 12 000 vote margin
there
what a mess guys what an absolute and
total mess
if you're just joining us we're live on
youtube twitch and facebook we're
looking at the latest numbers the latest
data
uh we just saw a completely unhinged
they're calling it a press
conference but it was really just pam
bondi chewing gum and yelling into a
bullhorn
loudspeaker and corey lewandowski
seemingly high as a kite
uh screaming at people so i don't i mean
the term press conference
is extremely loose it's a loose term i'm
using that term
generously let me put it that way but
they did say things and there was a
camera there so i think that's about as
far as i'm willing to go
kira mcmanus says your coverage of the
election results are brilliant
if the case goes to the supreme court to
stop counting votes or
a recount how would they rule no idea
i would not even think of guessing how
they would rule because it's so
so unpredictable okay i want to give you
guys some more updates on the last 24
hours but before i do that
um i do want to get some updated new
member numbers in this type of thing
we have an additional eight folks who
signed
up on my website which puts us at 18
and then from the standpoint of twitch
we're at 1980
which is another 28 puts us at
46. we do have this goal of 304
because that's the number i mean listen
this is just numbers but
that's the number of uh electoral votes
that donald trump got
in 2016. so it seems like uh
like a fair number okay let's look at
some crazy stuff from the last
few hours let me see we looked at the
trump twitter already
let's just see if he tweeted anything
else he has been
just losing it oh okay this
is in okay so i don't know if this is a
protest to start the vote counting or to
stop the vote counting
there's both going on simultaneously as
you guys know
sometimes you win by not counting
sometimes you win by counting i don't
even know
check this out they broke into song here
take a listen to this
from
[Music]
[Music]
oh the high notes crushing them
brutal
[Music]
okay so anyway these are defiant
protesters with
very powerful demands either that the
vote counting stop
or that the vote counting start even if
there are no
no more votes left to count i don't know
which type of protest this is let's look
at one other video from this
legal votes matter it's this is you
saturday night live is cancelled it's
saturday night live is
irrelevant and now at this point you you
there's no more reason for saturday
night live
so that was one protest uh okay i
already pointed out my tweets
now these are other protests these i'm
pretty sure
so that that first protest i think was
to start counting
this protest is to stop counting this
was from the tcf center in detroit
stop the vote stop the vote
so they don't want voting to happen i
guess
and uh let me see if there were any
other oh yeah i
uh showed this on the regular show today
on my podcast by the way if you guys
aren't subscribed to my podcast please
do it's completely free it's called the
david pakman show it's like
on every any platform you want um this
was an email sent
out saying they need poll challengers to
show up at the tcf center in detroit
and they did and um that's exactly
that's exactly what they did so that was
there then
this is this is also detroit
this is peop this is also a you have to
remember there's
stop and start the vote protest this is
a stop the vote protest
in the building
[Applause]
so the world continues to laugh at us
and then this
okay now this is a start the count
protest this one is in phoenix you'll
see
what at least one guy with a long gun in
this video and this one was in phoenix
here they do want voting
uh to votes to be counted
and you see this guy here has uh well
this guy's very sweaty
this guy has a long gun and it seems
almost like
a kevlar almost like a like a belly
protector i don't know what this guy
maybe that's kind of a utility belt or
something
anyway at least he's not fully decked
out in tactical gear because you know
that can get pretty crazy
here is uh here's another one
so that's a stop the steel protest the
firearms
increase this guy with an open carry gun
and a pretty pretty sizable flag i guess
and then um here was another guy this is
rich
who says he's 30 says he he's mad
because biden wants to tax his guns
like the ar-15 and as you can see uh
desert camouflage does not work well
um against back
blacktop i guess you know it's not
exactly
you know you're not going to really be
able to hide with that color there you
need a different different color
this guy this guy's an operator for sure
so that's going on um
so that that's kind of the gist of it oh
here's just one more this is also
arizona here they had a fox news sucks
chant this last one then we'll look at
the ballot count
a lot of people in the crowd are are not
wearing masks we're
we're keeping a respectful distance um
but a loud and very boisterous crowd
you'll start hearing them start up here
and they're actually chanting fox news
sucks fox news sucks the reason why
they're chanting that is because fox
news called
arizona for biden it's actually kind of
funny like it's msnbc so msnbc viewers
generally it's like you don't need to
explain to them why
fox news sucks but i like that the
reporter has the presence of mind to
realize that
the reason these people are chanting fox
news sucks
is very different from why the msnbc
audience believes
fox news sucks so you have to kind of
clarify the reason why
uh fox news sucks at least as far as
their they're concerned
um okay so we've gotten that out of the
way
oh okay last thing so this is kind of
funny i mentioned yesterday
that our election night stream which is
up beyond 1.4 million
views that you guys on youtube the
youtube viewers broke the subscriber
button
on election night and so yesterday when
we looked at the subscriber numbers from
the stream it said 33
because you triggered a spam alert on
youtube
too many people were signing up we now
have the numbers and somewhere between
uh five and six thousand new subscribers
came in during uh during that stream
which is just unbelievable just an
incredible number
uh as far as numbers are concerned it's
a really really really really strong
number
um okay very good so let's get to the
oh david perdue did fall below 50
that would trigger a runoff which is
delightful
i mean just absolutely absolutely
delightful
um oh yeah 1.1 million
we we actually i you guys tell me i
don't know if fox if
youtube rather has made the number
public because it sometimes takes a
while but we did hit 1.1 million
subscribers yeah we got over we got
beyond the 1 million we didn't hit 1.1
million just a few minutes ago so that
is
that's strong um okay let me get an
update on these numbers
so nevada nothing new again nevada gave
one small update they went from 75 to 76
percent today
it increased biden's lead by two tenths
of a point and then nevada said no more
i i don't get why pennsylvania
pennsylvania
is still at a 1.4 percent lead
for donald trump georgia
is still at a point two percent lead for
donald trump
and it is down to just um 85
no i'm sorry 9 500 votes 9 500 vote
margin there
and north carolina i don't know why if
someone in the chat wants to explain it
to me
there's been no new reporting from north
carolina for 24 hours
a couple people said they're reporting
nothing until
next wednesday or tuesday thursday or
something like that
i'm not too sure about that i just am
not sure about that and then refreshing
any state if joe biden gets any of the
four remaining states
uh he would clinch the presidency of the
united states
um you know one really interesting thing
and i don't i don't want to make too
much of this
breaking news david perdue below 50
beautiful news
i don't want to make too much of this
because i'm not really looking to like
go out and trigger people or anything
like that
but for the last four years
violent trumpists have been trolling me
incessantly on twitter
on instagram emailing me i'm getting you
know 20 voicemails a day from
jimmy from philly and from troy york and
all these different people
i haven't heard from a single trumpist
in 48 hours
and if indeed joe biden were to win
my prediction is you would just see
these trumpets
disappear for like six months and then
they would reappear
as anti-biden trolls six months from now
acting as if trump i don't know trump i
don't know anything about trump biden's
bad
i don't remember anything about trump
that's my prediction
that's my prediction about what we would
expect but i have to tell you
i love that i'm not hearing from them i
love that i'm not hearing from them
although let me just briefly look at my
voicemails to see if anybody did leave a
voicemail
because maybe we did hear they always
call from blocked numbers
uh oh i think that troy york did leave
one let's take a listen hold on
yeah david pakman i saw your latest
six-minute commentary
once again you speak with fort tong
this is not about trump the 67 million
people
do not necessarily vote for trump what
they vote against
is the corrupt global system
where rich people from other lands like
your family for instance
yeah so there you go so that's what you
have to understand when he says
global people like my family this is
code for jews
i really want people to understand this
that's code for jews globalist
as you all know for a while has been a
term that's wrapped up with just
anti-semitic conspiracies and the like
so when global people like my family
that means jews guys this is what we're
dealing with here and by the way
forked tongue yeah i know i'm skipping
over that obviously now i think it's
pretty clear
who have corrupted their own countries
can come here and meddle with our
affairs meddling forked
tongue globalists like me from other
countries
are meddling with united states affairs
enrich themselves
and and self-enrichment so i think
we've squeezed all anti-semitic tropes
into the first 30 seconds
anyway he goes on for three more minutes
but i won't give any of that to you
and then what else do i have
let me see if any so i guess there was
one trump troll that called in
but that's all i've got right now yeah
so anyway the point is the trump trolls
have certainly slowed down
they've slowed down that's for sure okay
um ms mrs hippie freak wants me to
explain a
senate runoff says she's 46 years old
and has never
heard of this okay let's do that let's
explain a senate runoff
so let's go to uh senate i will explain
this to you right now
let's look at georgia okay in georgia
right now
this is a three-way race incumbent
republican david perdue
democratic challenger john ossoff and
libertarian shane hazel
shane hazel in a three-way race so
in the jo in this georgia senate race
the winner must get 50
of the vote okay so in a three-way race
if david perdue gets 50
of the vote or 51 percent or 52 he wins
if no candidate gets a majority of the
vote
there is a runoff election between the
top two vote getters which in this case
would be david perdue or john ossoff you
eliminate shane hazel
and then david perdue and john ossoff
have a special election now
i i just i have to be
up front which is my instinct is
once you eliminate the libertarian the
libertarians go more for david perdue
than they do for john ossoff so i don't
see ossoff winning
with this exact electorate in the
recount now or another recount the
runoff
i don't know the exact runoff rules if
additional democrats can vote in the
runoff
maybe they would be buoyed by the
momentum of a potential biden win if we
get one and maybe john ossoff could take
it
that would be very interesting but that
is that is how a uh
that's how a runoff election works okay
a breaking news from joe biden
philadelphia you can perhaps uh
help us understand their pace and and
how they're doing
one of the things lester one of the
things i should tell you is that we are
to your point expecting a professor from
the secretary of state who oversees
elections here in this area that could
be huge
experts officials expect that most of
the voting will be counted
possibly by tomorrow and who knows maybe
even
sooner the numbers that we're seeing as
chuck has been pointing out
biden is shrinking trump's lead here
interestingly enough significant
shrinkage an aggressive campaign
in court to intervene in the mail
ballot counting they went into court
saying in their words
that election officials were hiding the
mail ballot counting
from republican poll observers
what they got this how funny is it that
most people would like to start counting
the mail-in ballots in pennsylvania as
they come in
the law is they can't start counting
them until the the polls close
now they're mad that the mail-in ballots
are suddenly being counted
it's it's lunacy philadelphia and where
the county is going
on behind me they paused the counting
because they said they wanted to review
that court ruling subsequently they
resumed that counting
and they say they're going furiously let
me just add a couple of numbers in here
to show you how
fast it seems to be going when i left
here from reporting at about one o'clock
in the morning
right the state was saying that they had
something like 763
000 mail-in ballots statewide still to
be counted wow when i came back at about
11 o'clock this morning that number was
369
000. wow that's upwards of 400 plus
thousand mail and ballots they had
counted so they say they're moving
furiously the state attorney general
here in pennsylvania has said
that they are going to count all of
these ballots regardless who it favors
they're planning to count every single
one of them lester
and we saw i think we had a graphic up
earlier that that biden is certainly out
performing
at a large level uh the president in uh
in philadelphia
um chuck you were looking so the big
news is very soon we're expecting
actually to hear from the pennsylvania
secretary of state about what is going
on with the count let's see if george
stephanopoulos or maybe even nate silver
here
uh have anything to say the secretary of
state just before that 90
of the remaining ballots are in clark
county which is very blue
i do not think there is a path back for
trump in nevada unless there's something
we don't know
um arizona's trigger we have different
types of ballots we have some
provisional ballots in arizona we have
some late arriving early ballots
we about to were dropped off on election
day i think trump's case is a bit more
plausible there but he needs a lot of
breaks to win in arizona
but nevada is a state where i just don't
think there's a path
so and and arizona is still an uphill
climb
arizona uphill but doable you can make
assumptions where arizona works out for
trump
nevada i i you know i think finally
biden's lead's going to grow there it
might wind up being a more comfortable
march in the end for him let's talk
about george and now we've seen the the
lead now climb go
drop into the teens right there and we
also potentially have two senate races
in play
yeah so if you look at the rate at which
biden
is accumulating votes he's winning votes
about 70 30 the mail votes so he is on
track
to actually overtake trump narrowly but
the the comment early about we don't
know for sure how many votes there are
that's important right if there are as
many votes as secretary of state says
or more i think biden is on track to
overtake trump but sometimes
there are different numbers of ballots
than you expect wow right sometimes
they've they've actually been processed
but the secretary did it didn't know the
county had finished it but they hadn't
turned it in
to the state yeah they can wind up in
limbo sometimes there's an over count or
an under count or it's provisional
ballots instead of
uncounted ballots so it's it's you have
to take everything with a certain
um grain of salt when you're kind of
looking at the number of
outstanding ballots and then when you go
up to pennsylvania you have several
hundred thousand
ballots in play one number i heard most
recently was about four hundred thousand
we've now seen joe biden uh close the
lead to below
one hundred thousand what does that tell
you i mean this is the big problem for
um for donald trump is pennsylvania
that's the one where it might
i mean there's uncertainty right but it
might not wind up being all that close
um you know because look i mean people
forget that like
it's not as though these are coming in
late per se they're often ballots that
were sent in by mail early
and the mail balloting in pennsylvania
now say they usually had a big absentee
program
it's just very very very blue biden
winning by 50 points in a lot of these
mail ballots and so
there's a certain inevitability in
pennsylvania even red counties in
pennsylvania the mail ballot is pretty
pro-biden and so i don't know i mean i i
can't imagine
a world where the math looks good for
trump maybe some
very interesting breathing patterns from
nate silver i've never noticed that
before but people are pointing it out
that is interesting
we are awaiting an update from the
secretary of state of pennsylvania
the people on fox news are you know
continuing to rant and rave
uh that's really really no surprise but
the numbers moving very very slowly
and nevada presumably done for the night
we could get a big as trump calls it a
ballot
dump and he gets really angry when these
dumps happen um
in pennsylvania georgia has gotten
exceedingly close
0.2 only 9 500.
in fact 9 525 9525 it looks like
a quick glance votes separating the two
candidates at this point in time
um and any one of these four states for
joe biden
would do it any any one of those four
states would do it for joe biden so
that's what we are monitoring
at this point in time um okay
what else do we i saw some people asking
do i think
covet news disappears if biden wins now
that's a trump talking point
and speaking of covid i i don't you know
it's hard to sometimes
keep at everything that is going on
there were 108 000 cases of coronavirus
yesterday this is a single day record
for the united states
and we're back to 1200 death deaths a
day
we're back to 1200 deaths a day today
already eight and let me refresh
actually
we're already we just found 11 000 new
cases while we were talking
97 000 new cases today and 980 deaths
so there is no chance that if joe biden
you know trump believes it's all
political so he's been saying on
november 4th if biden wins or whatever
you know whenever we find out
the winner oh hold on a second let's see
what's going on here
hey the uh philadelphia pennsylvania
secretary of state speaking
incredibly incredibly hard hundreds of
thousands of ballots have been counted
so far today
and we're in very good shape but there's
still
still some to count so they are working
incredibly hard they're going to keep
counting into the evening
and you know stay tuned so
let's see we have
uh we've been reaching out we've been
very closely in touch with all 67
counties
making sure that they're reporting on as
regular basis as possible
is there any news all of you everybody
around the country around the state are
eagerly
awaiting and i can tell you the counties
are too they are really
taking their time making sure that every
single voter
in the commonwealth who has cast their
ballot
is having those ballots accurately and
securely counted
so you know as you know
we're going to keep counting military
and overseas ballots i think
are coming in those will continue to be
accepted through next tuesday
there are obviously provisional ballots
that will have to be counted as well
after the initial round of ballots and
you know i think whatever whatever the
outcomes are
i can tell you that i'm so proud to work
with
the 67 counties the election officials
who are just
doing an amazing job getting these
counted accurately and securely
so i am happy i think with that
to take your questions yes the integrity
of the election
has certainly been questioned quite a
bit over the past several days and it
seems to be intensifying now
in these final states that we're waiting
to hear from
what is your message to the people of
pennsylvania
and the people of the country about the
way things work here in pennsylvania
so you know as we've been talking about
for months
pennsylvanians have more choices on how
they've been able to vote
this year than they've ever had in the
history of the commonwealth
and no matter how they voted what's
critical here
is that we have very strong processes in
place
that make sure that that voter in that
voting integrity and
security are constantly
constantly followed by every county in
the state so for example we talked about
i think it was yesterday voting by mail
in pennsylvania so the process is we
felt though
though it's new under act 77 that we can
all vote by mail
it's the same processes that we've used
for decades for absentee voting so
voters have to apply they're checked
against either social security database
or the penndot database
they're checked against their voter
record to make sure they're qualified
voter and they are who they say they are
they cast their ballot and then they're
checked again when the ballot is
received that they were actually
an approved voter very secure
there's there's really like the strength
of the integrity of this vote
is really unparalleled same when you
vote in person right you have to be
registered you go in
you sign in the poll book all these
things are tracked our
voting systems it seems we're not
getting any data
make sure that no voter can cast more
than one vote
it literally has a hard stop should
anybody even try
and the counties again as i've talked
about the amazing county election
officials
they take this so seriously they are
such professionals
so you know it i can just say really no
matter
how you chose to vote this year and so
many pennsylvanians have and it looks
like
it's really going to be great turnout
when we finalize the numbers
that every method is incredibly safe and
secure
yes i'm sorry
yes sir hi secretary hey you've said uh
if i if i understand it correctly that
enough results may be coming in tonight
for people to have a
handle on who the winner in the
presidential race is what's your basis
for thinking that can you put a
finer point on it how long what makes
you say that
so the counties are the counties are
continuing to count and so obviously
depending on how close the race is
that impacts whether you so you know
the the final results are not certified
until 20 days after the election right
so i want to be clear
there's no final results happening now
anyway what's happening now is having
enough ballots counted right
to actually see who the winner is right
the farther apart that is
the easier it is to tell so it's very
close
in pennsylvania right there's no
question and so
that means so do we want to stop the
count or or start the count in
pennsylvania i'm trying to figure out
what trump wants here
there's several hundred thousand ballots
remaining
to be counted you can track all that
what counties it remains in
look at our website and you'll be able
to see
how how we get to the conclusion but
you know either way i want to be clear
that
these are just the mail and absentee
votes and the in-person votes right the
overwhelming majority like
i think you know a huge huge majority of
the
in-person votes have been counted we're
in a very good place with the mail and
absentee ballots
but not quite there yet but then there's
still going to be provisional ballots
the military and overseas ballots and so
forth so the closer the races
the longer it takes but i think what
i've said all along
is that the overwhelming majority of
ballots will be counted by friday
i still think that we're ahead of the
schedule and we actually already have
counted the overwhelming majority of
ballots
but because it's a close race it's not
quite clear yet who the winner is so
yes kathy van buuvar she's the secretary
of state in
pennsylvania uh flashes of optimism
there and
not an easy job with the entire country
all right so that's the pennsylvania
secretary oh did we just miss biden
still waiting
to hear what that final vote oh no that
was yesterday that was yesterday oh i
would have been
very disappointed that was that was the
yesterday biden speech that would have
been sad
um and let's see what's happening on fox
news fox news still carrying this let's
pick up on a little bit of it
statewide and of those uh
how many have been counted and reported
so very few have been counted
and because the that usually happens
following the
counting of the other ballots so usually
so that you won't see counties are not
going to start that
until after they've finished with the
others generally um
so so we don't know yet we've been
reaching out to the counties i know i'm
the camera members you were somebody
else who asked me both about provisional
ballot numbers and
numbers of ballots arriving after
election day after epm on election day
um so provisional ballots you know i
think we've heard from
you know maybe two-thirds of the county
so i don't have a
firm number yet and as soon as we do
we'll be able to report
those numbers can you give me your best
estimate
the provisional ballots i think it's
still early yet
so let's touch base again after i have
more than the number that i have so far
yeah no guesstimate at all it doesn't
it's you know the context
the context matters right so if i tell
you a number that
ref reflects 41 counties it's not it's
it could not it could be not reflective
of the whole because it matters which
counties they are so
we will circle back with you yes
you sorry i know that you stand by the
integrity of the election so far
have you or any of the counties
investigated
any specific allegations of voter fraud
no no i mean i'm not aware of any i mean
well i should say
you probably heard some weeks ago
that there was a gentleman in lucerne
county who tried to apply for a ballot
for his deceased mother
are you sure he was a gentleman but that
was that was several weeks ago
that was the only incident that i am
aware of
in this in this year
yeah yes sir um i know that you said a
minute ago that you guys have counted
the vast majority of the in-person
election day votes
can you give us a more specific sense of
how many of those are outstanding is it
fewer than the remaining mail-in votes
oh yeah if you
go to our website and the supplemental
dashboard
if you look at like the pie chart it's a
tiny sliver it it may be that 99
or counted so if just but i whether it's
99 or 90.5
go to the dashboard and it will tell you
more beyond the male in balance better
no i mean there's a tiny fraction of
precincts
all right so i think we're getting a
sense here the the only real news is
they're counting ballots and she feels
really good about where they are as far
as the counting goes not as far as the
data
so as of right now no update
no update 90 000 votes
uh separate donald trump and joe biden
in pennsylvania
no update in north carolina at all today
georgia separated by 95
25 votes with 99
reporting and in nevada still no updates
with a 12 000
uh not even quite about 11 400 vote
margin
between the two candidates so that's
what we are seeing there
and i know people keep asking people
keep joining the the stream and saying
what's the status the status is this um
any one of these four states presuming
that alaska does eventually go for trump
and that there has been no problem with
the ap
and fox news calling arizona any one of
these four remaining states nevada
pennsylvania north carolina or georgia
um would seal the deal
for joseph r biden jr so that's where we
are
right now uh okay oh
by the way i haven't said a word about
popular vote
just to remind everybody what's going on
with popular vote
um donald trump has fallen below 48
of the popular vote most people voted
for joe biden more than 50 percent
joe biden's lead is now 3.57
check me on that 3.57
million more votes than donald trump
and as all of you probably imagine if
you're watching
from other countries um
one candidate got three and a half
million more votes it's sensible to me
to make them president of course we have
an electoral college system
and that is not exactly the way that it
works here and i know
by the way i i've been having a bunch of
people write to me lately saying
you know david you're missing some of
the upsides of the electoral college
um okay that that may be
but i'm still against it and we would
have a far
simpler uh situation here and a much
more representative one of just the
average person
the average person and that is what i
want that is what i want
um okay
oh people are saying biden did just
speak
if that's the case i would actually like
to grab that let's see how long ago was
it
um donald trump
yeah maybe i'd have to find that video
separately
let me see hold on a second is it on
does anybody know if it's on the joe
biden
youtube channel joe biden
joe biden live an hour ago oh it looks
like he gave a one minute statement okay
yeah let's just listen to that it's very
very short so we can listen to it
together
chris and i just completed uh briefings
on both covid and the economic crisis
facing this nation
and we're reminded again of the severity
of this pandemic
cases are on the rise nationwide and
we're nearing 240
000 deaths due to covet and our hearts
go out to each and every family that has
lost a loved one
to this terrible disease in america
the vote is sacred it's how people of
this nation
express their will and
it is the will of the voters no one
not anything else that chooses the
president of the united states of
america
so each ballot must be counted
and that's what we're going to see going
through now
and that's how it should be democracy is
sometimes messy
it sometimes requires a little patience
as well
but that patience has been rewarded now
for more than 240 years
with a system of govern governance and
that's been the envy of the world
we continue to feel senator and i we
continue to feel
very good about where things stand
we have no doubt that when the count is
finished senator harris and i will be
declared the winners
wow so i ask everyone to stay calm
all the people to stay calm the process
is working
the count is being completed and
we'll know very soon so thank you all
for your patience but we have to count
the votes
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops thank you so much
[Music]
wow um joseph r biden jr has said more
publicly and product provided more
public leadership in the
in the last 24 hours on coronavirus
than the actual president not sure if
that is uh
something you all have noticed but
that does not uh does not does not look
so good
for trump okay let me get some updated
numbers here we have for the first time
ever
breached 2 000 subs on twitch
and because we were previously at 1987
that gives us 14
more putting us at 60.
i also want to say thanks to people who
signed up on my website now 22
which is an additional 11 from where we
were putting us at 71.
let me i don't want to we have so much
going on i don't want to spend a lot of
time on memberships or anything like
that but i do want to mention two things
number one
we are counting twitch subs and website
memberships together now
people just seem to like it i don't know
everybody likes it so i'm doing it i do
what you guys want
um we will we are not stopping the count
i think is the point i'm trying to make
the count will continue and every
every membership every sub will be
counted that's my promise to you
but the other thing is we are taking a
fresh start now that we are beyond the
2020 election
and as a result we have a new coupon
code fresh start
all one word and it is oh what we just
lost twitch subs i think what's
happening is a lot of
months uh monthly memberships are
expiring right now that's weird we just
went down
my point is grab yourself a membership
at joinpacman.com it's our number one
funding source you know all these
different platforms they use algorithms
and complicated things are we on the on
their good side or on their bad side
facebook was great for us in october
facebook is down 80
in november why we don't know we never
know it's i'm not alleging that it's
fraud
and i'm not alleging that it's fraud i'm
not alleging either i'm just saying it's
very up and down
so if you've appreciated the streams the
last few days i would love it for you to
grab a membership at joinpakman.com
i encourage you to try to crash the
website we've quadrupled resources and
the website is feeling so strong right
now
and of course a fresh start as a coupon
code we'll save you 70
we've had a lot we've taken a lot of
cancellations lately i'll be honest
because of what's going on with uh with
the virus
economically you know another 800 000
people lost their jobs this week
and we've some some days we have 30 40
50 cancellations
so your support if you can throw a
couple bucks our way it's actually a
dollar it's like a dollar eighty a month
with the coupon code
it is very much appreciated also a huge
thank you to gotham chess levy rosman
for gifting 20 subs by the way if you
guys haven't seen
all of the great uh queens gambit
series related content just to get v
like
don't don't leave okay just we're
getting away from politics for like a
minute
there is a tremendous new series on uh
netflix called the queen's gambit
based on a novel about a young female
chess prodigy
who has a little bit of a hankering for
the tranqs if you understand what i'm
saying
um fantastic series and a lot of great
uh chess streamers including our friend
levi
rosman have been doing great content
around it it's
an absolutely fantastic series and
i encourage you to check out the series
check out
um levy's content on it and some of our
other friends alex botez
um a god mature he's not really i don't
think he even knows i'm alive but
i i think he does some good content
they've all been doing great stuff i
don't know if our friend
ben feingold has done content on the
series
but um ben feingold's also a good guy
and sometimes he's in the chat so i want
to mention him but yes beth
harmon uh often encouraged to play the
sicilian
doesn't always do it doesn't always do
it but check it out it's really really
good
and am i reading anything right now i
mentioned yesterday i'm getting through
some of um blake crouch's older work
blake
crouch a uh great friend of the show
i've interviewed him before
uh okay hold on what's what's going on
here oh this is earlier we already
we played this earlier um yeah i don't
know what else uh
i'm reading good economics for hard
times as well
by abhijit i believe his name is abhijit
banerjee and his wife esther duflo
oh and by the way one of just one other
thing before people
completely rip my head off for doing
non-politics stuff
the actress in queen's gambit anya
taylor joy
she is half argentinian now i'm full
argentinian she's half argentinian if
you find
interviews of her being interviewed in
spanish she speaks
with the same argentinian accent that i
speak with beautiful moment beautiful
moment
okay i'm told donald trump jr is
tweeting
absolutely ungodly things
on twitter so let's take a look at that
donald trump
jr let's see what he's i can only
imagine he's been losing it all day
um this was flagged by twitter
wtf if it doesn't exist nothing will be
exposed why would they be against
finding election fraud
his previous tweet was the total lack of
action from virtually all of the 2024
republican hopefuls is amazing
they have a perfect flat platform to
show that they're willing and able to
fight but they will cower to the media
mob instead
don't worry trump will fight and they
can watch as usual
oh my god who who cares
what don jr is saying he's out of his
mind
saying no one's surprised that lindsey
graham hasn't tweeted in 24 hours
retweeting lou dobbs saying this is the
most corrupt election in american
history no it's not
no it's not um
what on earth is he talking about
oh 6 p.m oh oh this is good so maybe we
can catch this
georgia republican committee woman
ginger howard will hold a press
conference
at 6 p.m eastern okay that i would like
to find
um does anybody know who is they're
filing lawsuits everywhere
they don't even know who they're suing
and for what okay people also want me to
pull up
greta tunberg's twitter that she's
trolling trump
let's see what she had to say um
so ridiculous donald must work on his
anger management problem then go to a
good old-fashioned movie with a friend
chill donald chill okay very good so
greta tunberg getting in on the action
so georgia republican press conference
let's see if anybody's scheduled to
carry it
um
i'm not seeing anything if anybody's
aware
of who might be covering that my hope
is that either abc or nbc
will cover that at the top of the hour
so far no mention
of it this is the pennsylvania election
update which we already
saw uh let's take a just a brief listen
and see what nbc is saying
lawsuits that might stick in other
states
well there's both the legal fight and
the public relations fight on the
latter part uh we heard from andrew
bates a campaign spokesperson saying
simply that this is not the behavior
of a winning campaign trying to argue
that the fact that they're
trying to get lawyers involved rather
than voters involved shows
what they think all right so we'll keep
an eye on this uh
there's some completely unhinged
republican event in georgia planned for
the top of the hour so let's see what
happens i'm excited to see what it is
that they're going to say
okay um let's see steve bannon called
for fouchy and the fbi director to be
beheaded
oh come on guys check your twitter
notifications if people can confirm that
that's actually true and get me a tweet
link i will pull it up
i don't want to be tricked if that that
sounds completely impossible
um so if people can f if people find oh
he did people are saying he did there's
no way
hold on steve bannon twitter
steve bannon stephen k bannon it's on
video
hold on steve i'm trying to kind of like
triage it myself
uh i'm not seeing anything
it's on a video of a show he did okay
let's see
steve bannon fouchy behead i mean how is
this even possible
on a podcast appearance
yeah i don't know if people can get the
link to jaby gatz one of our twitch
moderators
jaby gatz is gonna can can triage it
and then um will let me know uh people
saying just search twitter for bannon
let's see bannon
i'm not going to share the video but
steve bannon called for the beheading of
dr
oh my god
oh my god look at this and that's the
second term second term kicks off with
firing ray
firing fouchy now i actually want to go
step farther but i raise the
president is a kind-hearted man and a
good man i'd actually like to go back to
the old uh times of tudor england
i'd put the heads on pikes right oh my
god two corners of the white house as a
warning
to federal bureaucrats either get with
the program
or you're gone time to stop playing
games blow it all up but
put rick grinnell today as the interim
head of the fbi
that'll that'll light some that'll light
him up right you know what steve just
yet
how is that not terrorism
what i'm just gonna send this to myself
because i'll probably want to cover that
wow i uh i you know in other times
my skepticism that steve bannon
would that that such someone so closely
associated with the president would call
for the beheading of the top infectious
disease doctor
we could have ignored it uh i was wrong
i was wrong to assume that steve bannon
was not
calling for people to be beheaded it is
unbelievable oh people want to see the
rest of the video okay we can do it
yesterday there was the anniversary of
the hanging of
two tories in philadelphia these were
quaker businessmen who had uh
cohabitated if you will with the british
while they were occupying philadelphia
these people were hung this is what we
used to do
traitors that's how you won the
revolution nobody wants to talk about
revolution wasn't some sort of garden
party
right oh my god civil war it was a civil
war
yeah a lot of people i thought i was
getting baited people in the chat
thought i was getting baited
and then it's like he says yeah put it
put their heads on pikes
let me just hear it one more time that's
the second term second term kicks off
with firing ray
firing fouching now i actually want to
go a step farther but i raise the
pressure there's people saying that he's
suggesting that they be hung not
beheaded but if you put their heads on
pikes haven't you removed their heads
as a kind-hearted man and a good man i'd
actually like to go back to the old uh
times of tutor england
i'd put the heads on pikes right i put
them at the two corners of the white
house
as a warning okay yeah see he is talking
about b i mean
if you i think you need to do that in
order anyway i don't want to get into
the uh oh they were joking oh ok i
gotcha it was just
all a joke it's a joke guys i'm sorry
okay
um andrew says should i be sharing this
rebroadcasting death threats is not a
good idea fauci's a public person oh
here's the georgia of oh no this is
earlier let's see what was said earlier
actual results are reflective of the
voters intent
the the issue we have in georgia is like
i said it's a close vote
there's other states that have more
votes to count than we do but it's a
wide margin so
nobody cares so this is the first time
we've used paper ballots in this state
in 20 years
voted is donald trump holding a point
okay so they're expecting another
we're about 10 minutes from more some
more insanity coming from the
atlanta republican party if somebody
does
have a specific link to this event
scheduled in georgia with the republican
party in 10 minutes
somehow let me know that it's going on
because i'm hoping that someone will
will take it
um priscilla thompson here is in atlanta
and we're watching a couple of different
streams but it's possible that they also
won't we're keeping an eye on fox news
as well
um you know greg gutfeld this is a funny
story about greg gutfeld
somehow greg gutfeld came across oh
here's here's the greg gutfeld story
i want greg gutfeldt said something that
sounded crazy to me
and i retweeted it with my commentary
and then
um he wrote back and he said you know
it's being taken out of context
and i looked at it in in broader context
and it was true that his comment it was
about nazis or something was taken out
of context
so i corrected it and he wrote to me
privately and he said hey you know what
i really appreciate that a lot of people
won't do that
uh i i look forward to seeing your
content
i'm gonna follow you and for a while
greg gutfeld was
following me and then it didn't last
very long clearly he wasn't liking what
i was um
what what i was tweeting so then he very
quietly unfollowed me and i never heard
from him again so that's my that's my
greg gutfeld story
um big dave rubin friend he's a big dave
rubin friend greg gutfeld i think
all right let's get updated numbers from
my website
we now have 60 website subscribers
which is an additional 38 putting us
at 109 also over on twitch
we went from 2001
to 2043 which is an additional 32
putting us at 141. how's that for some
math huh
can you imagine um
oh you got oh people saying i should see
it what was going on
trump going live in 45 oh is that true
oh i don't want to miss a trump event
let's take a look at that
trump is that actually let's see
all of his tweets seem acosta tweeted
about it okay he hasn't tweeted about it
if trump's going live we we have to
cover that
uh okay white house trump to speak in
briefing room
at 6 30. oh boy i was going to cut the
stream at 6 30.
the thing is that probably means he's
not he's not coming back until like 8
p.m
uh let's see if there are any who would
be covering it
trump press briefing
that is going to be an absolute mess
i can't even imagine what that's going
to be like
okay let's see if anybody else is
announcing that that's going to be
happening
exactly that ruling came down earlier
around midday today
and essentially this lawsuit was filed
earlier this week
and it stems from uh two republican
poll observers they're not mentioning it
here yet but
i do think it's important to make clear
there is no basis in law
for a claim that counting must stop
simply because it sounds like
the president likes how the numbers look
it's nice on november 3rd
you're watching and you see who won the
election but you know what
we won't know we might not know for
months right no i think we'll know in a
couple days
uh and then fox news here
um not saying anything either okay so we
are expecting
donald trump at the bottom of the hour
that's very interesting very very
interesting
david his advisors are trying to stop
him from speaking
can somebody get me a link on that where
are people finding that that would be
fascinating if that were true
uh his advisors are trying to stop him
from speak that's hilarious
oh my god that what wild times we live
in that is incredible
cnn was talking about it um
trump is going to put out a call to arms
from the proud boys
imagine if donald trump actually does do
something like that that that would
really be crazy that would be insane
okay uh trump going to speak at 6 30. a
lot of
uh super chat's telling me trump is
going to speak at 6 30. okay in that
case
this is what we're going to do um i i
want to do a
um let me think about the right way to
do this should i be doing a new stream
for trump or should we just keep this
one going
not actually sure uh let's look at the
latest numbers
nothing new in nevada pennsylvania
wow pennsylvania now down to a 1.2
margin only 21-79
000 votes now separating the two
candidates
north carolina still at 1.4
and then georgia still at 9 500 votes
separating the two incredible okay yeah
we'll do we'll keep this stream
going um yeah that's that's fine uh
let's see yeah i may do a break at like
six uh
6 15 or something in anticipation of
trump
wow i can't even imagine what kind of an
idea
oh hold on i'm gonna have to re refresh
the twitch numbers
if i were trump's advisors i would also
be telling him hey maybe you don't want
to
show up and speak because that
what could he possibly do to help
himself oh our subscriber numbers just
got messed up
let me fix that there we go
i just don't understand what he could
possibly do that helps his case
unless he's looking to
instigate unless he's looking to
instigate in which case that could be a
very very different situation
um okay some questions coming in via zoo
super chat
if we can get a majority in the senate
and the white house do you think we
should expand the supreme court to 13 or
15 seats
um i'm not sure i've talked about
expanding
i don't know about 13 versus 15.
not sure about that i'm being asked to
look at the arizona numbers more closely
arizona has um
the lead am i correct that the lead has
grown in arizona now it's 2.3 where it
was a little bit smaller can somebody
correct me
arizona lead seems to have expanded
narrowing oh dear
okay and folks saying that
i should pick up the cnn feed let me see
that cnn live stream let me just find
that for you guys
because if things are happening on cnn
then certainly that's something we want
to see
where are we on cnn's content
here we go cnn
commercial breaking progress okay good
so we've got the cnn feed in case that's
where it happens
so if you're just joining us it has been
announced that donald trump will be
speaking
at the uh what's going on here that are
you know we are seeing a blue ship and
trending towards joe biden
um that we are expecting to hear from
donald trump at the bottom of the hour
what he is going to say i have
absolutely no idea
but i hope you'll you'll stay with us
for that because i assume
it will be completely and utterly
unhinged
let's um let's do this
let's i'm going to briefly pause and get
reset
so we'll pick up this coverage when i
come back i'm going to hear from a few
people on discord okay
davidpakman.com discord and that'll get
us
to the trump press briefing at the
bottom of the hour so let's do that
i'll be back in five furious with fox
news but i think we need to have a
reality check here about
what the president actually has access
to in terms of a legal recourse
elena we're not only watching the tight
presidential race over in georgia
another state that we want to talk about
but we're also watching the senate races
there
looks like georgia is going to have two
senate runoffs in january i mean this
state
has really become a key player in this
election
it has and it's remarkable i know that a
lot of people especially those in the
trump campaign were not expecting it
to be nearly this close and
i've definitely been fretting about it
internally but i will say it's
remarkable to look at
the the two senate races that are likely
heading for a runoff i mean
they will potentially decide which party
controls the majority in the senate
which is a huge deal we might not know
until january and that means that really
we're going to start to see a campaign
2.0 in these next few months uh vying
for those seats so a big deal there and
definitely
raising a lot of concerns within trump
world and republicans
uh that it is so close both on the
presidential level but then also
on uh the senate level in the special
election all right elena jackie thank
you both so much for being with us stick
around we're going to catch up with you
on some other states in play here
a little bit later in the show
appreciate it
good morning welcome to today we're glad
to have you with us this fall
we're right there with you whether
you're back to school what do you guys
think rick sir
we're back to work we're keeping you
safe i
love being back every morning on today
[Music]
washington feels more chaotic than ever
it's my job to ask the tough questions
left and right and help you make sense
of it all
are you ready go to work election night
in america continues races
she's joe biden's choice to be next in
line but who is
here join me joy to explore
[Music]
[Music]
should people be with concerned holt
53 to the tour good morning we're glad
to have you with us
this fall we're right there with you
whether you're back to school
after seeing the most comprehensive
police reform bill ever
introduced in congress i've begun to
wonder
if now is the time if now is
the time the protesters finally win
moments the last
nbc news correspondent ellis is in
philadelphia tonight nbc news reporter
barrett is
[Music]
what is the latest over ballot counting
there in philly uh over joe biden right
now in both pennsylvania and georgia
i talked to an advisor
biden commonwealth in favor of the
company
all afternoon
officials there in pittsburgh telling
you about the results raising the
president
uh i suspect some of that is on his mind
a pretty good spot here in allegheny
[Music]
telling aids and allies that he is very
upset with what has been a friend
and i suspect you may hear some of that
as well we'll see if the president takes
questions
but he obviously has a lot on his mind
he's been watching joe biden
making these statements over the last
couple of days calling for patience
this
is
all right guys i'm back and it seems
like there's actually two audio streams
playing right now i apologize for that
i've already counted the people who
voted oh my god okay
let's mute this we are standing by for
donald trump at the bottom of the hour
it's
absolutely crazy that donald trump is
going to speak
i can only imagine that donald trump is
going to make all sorts of additional
unfounded fraud allegations this seems
like a really bad idea like a really bad
idea
but he's going to do it so we are
starting to see
the events pop up i'm going to start
getting some of them ready for you guys
because uh this is going to be wacky
this is going to be completely wacky
uh let's see donald trump jr
and georgia republicans i guess are also
going to be speaking
and they're already supposed to be
speaking let's pull up that things
a lot of things are happening so i'm
glad that we're going to have the
opportunity to see all of them
donald trump jr and georgia republicans
make a statement in atlanta oh my god
which will be more unhinged i don't even
know
and then where else let's see if i can
get an additional
uh trump press briefing
trump holds a press briefing all right
this is probably good
we probably have all of the right uh
things going on
at this point in time this is going to
be nuts
i i have no idea what to expect i have
no idea what to expect
okay let's i want to hear from a few of
you guys
okay so if you want to get in touch get
into our discord
davidpakman.com slash discord
and i want to hear from a few of you
guys let me get an update on our
member numbers and see where we are we
are at 72 on the website
which puts us at plus 12 which is 153
and we're at 2067 on twitch
which is another 24 which puts us at
177.
beautiful beautiful number and thanks to
odwd
inc for gifting 20 subs
very much appreciate that here's the
process
for talking to me you go to
davidpakman.com
discord you get into the waiting lobby
you make sure that you are on do not
disturb
and you change your nickname to location
colon name all right location colon name
let me get myself logged in here
and then i need we have really strong
three factor authentication going on
here
let's see here we've got that
davidpakman.com discord
is the discord server for people who are
asking
um appreciate the super chats coming in
as well
um let's take a look here and see who
wants to chat
we have oh wow there's like 200 people
waiting which is nuts
let's talk to um
wow i i just i these are scroll i'm
gonna have to wait for it to like settle
down a little bit
how about um
[Music]
let's go to i can't even click one
because other ones scroll past this is
insane
we might have to set a limit maybe our
mods could do that where you set some
kind of a limit
on the number of people that can even be
holding let's go to our caller from
paris i can't see your name who is this
caller from paris
hello hello paris you're on the air
caller from paris please on mute you are
on the air
all right no such luck there let's go
next
to uh
let's go to alden from columbus georgia
alden from columbus georgia you're on
the air
alden from columbus georgia you're on
the air
hey i just had a
quick question for you um how
exactly so
there with it being this close of a race
do you still see
um
yeah can you hear me oh yeah okay
um do you still see trump's kids running
in 2020 or 2024 or
is that kind of a no i thought that that
was a real risk if trump gets re-elected
i think the odds of a trump kid running
go down dramatically if trump loses
okay yeah and do you see trump
going for re-election
again in 2024 yeah you're going
completely robot voice
i don't i know trump is talking about
running in 2024 if he loses but i don't
think he'll do it he'll be like 80 years
old
i don't think he'll do it
yeah all right thank you i'm gonna let
you go because it's just a little bit
crazy let me see if i can get back to
our paris collar the problem may have
been on my end there
um oh no paris caller is gone
i apologize that's not good let's go to
rose from
massac i can't see what it's like
m-a-s-a-q
i don't know what that is
rose are you there yeah can you hear me
yes i can oh um so
thanks for calling on me uh masak is
actually an orbital from ian banks's
culture series
ah okay i'm i'm a total nerd
so this is more of a question but
we've passed a really green milestone in
terms of climate
yes and we've passed a very important
trigger point
um i'm not sure if you know about this
but the blue ocean event
a lot of scientists have warned about
just happened
i'm not familiar with that oh so
the blue ocean event is this point in
time
when the arctic uh ocean doesn't freeze
over
so because you have a lower reflectivity
as well as um higher absorption
in the water you get a warmer octet
and because as the arctic gets warmer it
starts releasing methane from
the permafrost more got it this creates
a cycle so for the first time in
recorded human history
the lactif in the arctic ocean which is
where mostly ice gets produced
hasn't frozen over yet this is
unprecedented everyone like all of the
indices like the i triple c
and so on thought this would happen in
2040
or 2050. like
the models were wrong in the sense that
they weren't aggressive enough
got it and and uh i i hate to interrupt
that that's that's disturbing
did you have a question for me today
yeah why like so this is the most
important thing
like we could possibly be talking about
and no one knows about it you know well
now i do i appreciate you bringing it to
my attention so now i
will look into it and uh very very much
appreciate you letting me know about
that
um updates on the numbers we do have a
tightening again
in pennsylvania maybe no we don't it's
still 1.2 that hasn't changed
nevada hasn't changed arizona 2.2 is a
tightening we have a tightening in
arizona oh my god that is not looking
good
so we're gonna have to keep waiting on
that
let's go to uh where are we going to go
next
let's go to uh
oh okay our paris caller is back i
apologize it was my fault at the
beginning paris caller but i can't see
your name
hi is it me yes it is oh
hi thanks for taking me uh
i wanted to ask like do you think
once if biden gets elected
uh do you think there will be like
some kind of for a review of what
the trump administration
could have done that isn't known
something like that and what would
happen
like if we discover that they have done
some
wrong thing are you saying will there be
investigations of what happened during
the trump administration yeah for
example
i certainly hope so
yeah i don't know that there will i
don't know that there will but i i mean
there should be i think we don't know
the half of it to be perfectly frank
yeah uh i think so as well yeah
okay um that's yeah that's what i wanted
to ask
thank you very much uh are you are you
in paris you you live in paris
uh like near paris in the suburbs oh
okay
i have cousins in the suburbs oh
wow i actually i don't remember but i
probably shouldn't say anyway because
they're pretty
some of the it's a pretty small suburb i
don't want them getting harassed you
know
oh i see yeah
well if you want to come back again
oh believe me after the pandemic paris
is one of the first places i am going to
go
it's a nice city yeah beautiful city
okay thank you very
much love to hear from our friends in
paris let me go next
to shannon and i don't know if this is
someone calling from shannon who hasn't
told me their name
or someone named shannon who hasn't told
me where they're calling from but
shannon you were on
shannon good evening you are on
and last chance for shannon
oh shannon bailed okay all right let's
go to
um let's go to uh zach from salt lake
city
utah i was looking at the utah counties
today zach salt lake city
powerfully blue in a very red state
hey david are you there yes i am i can
hear you
hey i just wanted to thank you for um
your coverage on the election i really
appreciate it i've been looking forward
to your live streams every day
oh thank you just wanted to express my
gratitude anything crazy you want to
tell me about that's going on in salt
lake city
uh no it's just uh just me
and a couple family members that are
surrounded by uh
lots of republicans all the time so it's
a very interesting
environment to be around now i've heard
that being in salt lake city
if you're liberal and not mormon
actually really isn't bad
oh it's not um i'm
i grew up mormon but i'm no longer
anymore but i oh really
yeah and did is your family still mormon
yep wow and so and you guys get along
fine
oh yeah perfectly fine that's
interesting very understanding
yeah what's the um are they liberal
mormons
um it's a weird dichotomy in my family
so my mom has always been a really
devout republican
okay um and i think my dad is kind of on
the same spectrum as i am
um so it's kind of a an interesting
dynamic
i recently read a very interesting book
by john krakauer
the great john krakauer of uh into the
air
into thin air into the wild etc
called under the banner of heaven about
some mormon murders and it has a lot of
different insight into
um the mission and i'm sorry is there a
particular name for the the two-year
period before college
is it called a mission yeah lds mission
it's not necessarily before college just
kind of whenever one wants to go and do
it my i have a twin brother that
actually went on a mission
really identical or fraternal identical
yeah he served in atlanta georgia
wow and do now have you ever been
mistaken for
the missionary guy have not no it hasn't
hasn't happened okay good
um interesting stuff well yeah anyway i
recommend the book under the banner of
heaven very interesting about uh
gives you a lot of history of of
mormonism as well as
um you know the story of these murders
yeah interesting i'll have to check it
out thanks man all right very good okay
great to hear from you
uh let's see here let's go to pablo from
santiago now that could be chile that
could be
santiago de compostela in spain
hello let's go to pablo
oh boy you gotta listen in in discord
rather than in the stream pablo
hey david hello
hey am i am i invited
can you hear me you are live in vivo
director
well amazing i'm from chile can we speak
just a tiny bit in spanish please
okay so he's we can speak spanish i'll
translate decima
okay uh
yeah i'm actually i'm actually nervous i
didn't think i
i could have had the chance to talk to
you
oh you're doing great so so what what he
said was that
uh he's very and it sounds like you have
a phone going off that he's um a fan
from chile and that we have many fans in
chile and that
it's all everything is good and that i'm
an argentinian brother
yeah thanks okay thank you all right wow
what an international show we have going
today let's go to ian from new york next
ian from new york you are on as we are
if you're just joining us
don't even think about going anywhere
else because donald trump is about to
deliver
completely unhinged rantings that's my
characterization
um okay sorry uh back to the new york
call
ian from new york yes i can you can hear
me right i can hear you
as well uh hi i was just curious on your
thoughts about
uh possible reprisals from the trump
uh sort of trump uh administration
or his like i know he's gathering a lot
of militias so if
if briden were to win uh what are your
thoughts on like
possible violence that could come well
hold on you're saying trump is
trump himself is gathering militias or
there are militias that
wishes that support trump yeah okay okay
yeah i'm worried about it
i mean listen you've you've already
started to see it rear it's sort of ugly
head you've got people showing up
in michigan demanding stop counting you
have people showing up in arizona with
guns demanding start counting
um there's a lot that is going on so i
i think it could boil trump has my
the worst scenario for violence i
predicted would be
a a very narrow win for biden with trump
claiming it was rigged
that's the way it's pointed right now so
that's scary
hello
okay ian's gone very good it was a good
question it was a good question
let's go to sasha from new jersey sasha
from new jersey you were on as we stand
by for donald trump
hey david can you hear me yes i can
uh so first off uh big fan of your show
and
also i had a question what do you think
about
faithless electors potentially stealing
this election because yes
i'm getting more and more emails about
this so as many let me explain to the
audience
when a state has an election
like for example nevada and they have
six electoral votes
after the election is certified those
there are
actually six electors who
say we go for trump those electors
in theory uh because it is a mechanism
meant to protect from
certain bad situations they could say
one of those electors could say oh
i'm voting for trump even though nevada
went for biden if it goes for biden
if it's 270 to 268 as it could be we
don't yet know
um an elector one elector going the
other way
is a real problem um i am not really
taking a position on it right now i
think we
we i can't even con i can't even think
about that right now to be perfectly
frank and so i'm just waiting to see
first let's see who wins and then we'll
talk about faithful selectors
sounds good yeah good thank you all
right my pleasure
it's an important question and one that
i understand why it is being asked
updates in nevada nothing in arizona
2.2 in pennsylvania
1.2 for trump in north carolina still
1.4 for trump no update there in about
36 hours
and in joja still 0.2
a 9 500 vote lead for uh
for donald trump and we are standing by
for
prompt he has i guess convinced his
advisors to let him speak
i'm expecting it to be absolutely insane
i'm expecting it to be bonkers let's go
next to uh
oh let's go to a call from argentina
guido
from argentina
hello
argentina you are on
argentina you are on
guido that's too bad
was really looking forward to speaking
to someone from argentina that's sad
let's go to bethany from oklahoma
bethany from oklahoma you're on the air
hi can you hear me loud and clear
bethany
awesome um i guess my question is
i've been seeing some of my liberal
friends here in oklahoma which
there aren't a lot okay um we are
i mean there is not a single blue county
here but um
i have been seeing people talk about why
biden is not um getting hispanic vote
in texas like beto was
in texas and so i kind of wanted your
opinion on that i guess there
was a county that beta won um by like 26
points that trump got fifty percent of
the
fifty six percent of the vote in so two
thoughts
your opinion oh you is your dog here too
oh i'm in the backyard with my daughter
oh what kind of a dog is it
well that's actually the loud neighbor
dog because i have a husky
who um is in heat and so the neighbor
dog is kind of freaking out
oh my god it sounds like things are
crazy there you're the dog is in heat
right now
my well she's she's ending her cycle
right okay oh my god
the na the neighbor is a big fan yeah
and you haven't uh
you've decided not to spay well
i years ago thought i wanted um
maybe uh to keep one of her puppies but
i've kind of changed my mind because
i've
i don't know i i don't really want to
breed her anymore
but i just haven't gotten around to
fixing her because she's kind of old now
so
have you thought about convalescent
plasma for her
no what is that i don't know if you're
i don't know if you're kidding right now
but your reaction was perfect but no
let's move on
um so here's the here's the thing i i
don't know that it's that relevant to
compare
the the biden numbers to the beta
numbers i would be comparing the biden
numbers to the hillary numbers and in
some places it doesn't look so good in
some cases it's okay
i'm actually planning um for my spanish
language show
i'm gonna be doing an interview about
exactly that issue and maybe we'll do it
in
english subtitles on it but i'm still
looking into the reasons why
is um i know you've kind of talked about
it is there a good place to go to watch
those
um spanish episodes i just that's really
neat that you do that you know
really right now it's not even online um
you have to have um a cable channel
called estrella
or trisha as we would say in argentina
and it's you have to check your local
listings i can't believe i'm saying that
but you do have to do it
gotcha yeah we just really use our apple
tv we don't even have local
channels or anything it's actually you
know you can get it on
some uh there's some website called i
think it's fubo
f-u-b-o that has the show it's a weird
thing
i i if the show if it becomes a regular
thing i hope to kind of make it more
uh clear how to get the show online
cool yeah that sounds neat i have some
um you know hispanic friends that would
be
pretty interested in that i think so
right right excellent
all right very good and listen can can
you get a good bagel in oklahoma
a good bagel i mean i think so of course
i'm not very cultured
um okay but um
we have a restaurant that's like called
old school
bagel cafe um kind of i think
supposed to be framed after it's like
called maybe it's even called like new
york old school
bagel cafe and it's one of the most
popular um lunch spots in town so i live
in a college town in stillwater oklahoma
actually
so kind of more of a progressive spot at
least but okay so it seems like the
if there's a place where you could get a
good bagel and maybe a reasonable
cappuccino
that you don't have to throw back at the
barista it seems that would be the place
yes we have a local coffee place that
beats starbucks
for sure it's uh they roast their own
coffee beans and everything here
perfectly
it's called aspen coffee and it's great
so wow people actually mentioning it
in the in the chat it looked like it was
before you said it anyway a bunch of
people in the chat mentioning it
really yeah it's fascinating well thanks
for taking my call
okay thank you yeah now it sounds like a
cat is going crazy so i'm to let you go
it's my daughter oh it's your daughter
oh okay sorry about that okay
all right very good thank you appreciate
it um we are hearing from donald trump
very very soon
it looks like um so we are going to
i'm in a disconnect for the time being
from discord because we're expecting
donald trump
absolutely any moment um some people are
saying trump is already live but i am
not seeing that on the fox news feed
or on this i'm not seeing it on any feed
whatsoever
but um it should be starting soon so
we're keeping an eye on it this is not
live biden by the way you're not missing
anything we've already we've already
reviewed that
okay let me get a final member count
because we do i i don't want to uh
before this starts
we're at 81 on the website that's plus
eight
on the website putting us at 190 i'm
sorry 185
from the perspective of twitch we're at
2069
which is plus two putting us at 187
beautiful if you're just joining us we
are about to hear from donald trump
against the best advice of his advisors
donald trump will be speaking tonight
okay um i would love it if you
um stayed around for this i don't know
what to expect it's gonna be a mess
i can only i can only imagine um
tyler says i was one of the owners of
the old school bagel in stillwater now i
own a spot
wait a second is tyler ford saying
that he was an owner of the bagel place
that the caller just mentioned
is that is that what's going on
what on earth are the odds of that
that can't be right so a caller mentions
the one bagel cafe and then tyler says i
used to own the bagel cafe that's crazy
and he paid five bucks to let us know it
must be true
well i don't know okay in any i don't
really know what's going on
okay um people are telling me that there
is stuff happening
in the press briefing room let me see if
i can find a better feed
um trump press
briefing uh
and let's see if any of these are live
live u.s reserve trump floods
i'm sorry guys i'm not finding a live
feed oh wait right oh god right side
broadcasting
is live in the room okay i guess i can
turn it on just for a few minutes
i tend not to want to do that just
because it's just so
toxic uh but there is that
maybe fox news will be live soon
and what else do we have here
um other live feeds
i think we'll get it i think with what
we have going on right now we will
certainly know
uh let's take a look fox not yet live
this is from the other day okay let's
keep it here for now this seems this
seems to be the best spot
to um to keep it going for the time
being okay good
paula says good luck paula white says
good luck
good luck from canada go america go blue
yeah it's uh you know
let's see how it goes dirgi's says
nevada only updates voting numbers once
a day around around 9 a.m pacific
yeah it's very slow let's take one more
look before we hear from trump
um arizona it's still 2.2 georgia 0.2
north carolina 1.4
and pennsylvania 1.2 no updates i don't
anticipate we're going to hear very much
more um
from any of these today i i don't know i
could be wrong about that but i don't
think we're gonna hear much more
um okay people asking what happened to
2020 now that's funny
okay so yeah people noticing we had this
great coupon code
2020 now 66 percent off it was crazy
crazy crazy
people were getting arrested because the
discount was so big and then it was gone
we have replaced it with something new
the election is
over so our new coupon code is fresh
start
we've upped the discount from 66 percent
to 70 and i invite you
yes you to go to joinpakman.com and to
grab one of those um
grab one of those memberships we have
now uh let me see who else did
that 83
okay so that's another two people which
puts us at 189
and then on twitch we're at 2070 which
is also
plus one puts us at 190. we're trying to
get to 304
members and twitch subs because that's
one for every elect or
electoral vote that donald trump had in
2016.
that's where the number comes from i
don't know what else to tell you
uh wow and we may get there because
there's all of a sudden 128 people on
the membership page on my website that's
bonkers i don't even know that that's
legal to be perfectly frank
that may not even be allowed yeah i'm
going to look into that
i am told there is a small update on the
new york times
site for pennsylvania let's look at that
yeah i can't imagine what donald trump
is going to say it's going to be a com
oh
that's senate hold on let me go to
president
and pennsylvania
1.1 wow yeah this is now down to 75
000 uh 74 700 747
something like that pennsylvania getting
extraordinarily close but they are
starting to run out of vote
right i mean we're at 93 reported
based on an estimate based on an
estimate
uh let's see if anybody else is carrying
trump yet
nope just waiting on trump let's see
what cnn's doing
president trump to make remarks soon fox
news
awaiting okay so i think we're i'm i'm
feeling solid guys that we're not going
to miss the trump briefing
i do think that we're going to uh we're
going to get it
uh super chats two kyles weighing in
kyle craven says in her book mary trump
outlines how he's not mentally able to
process defeat
i fear this snowballs and we actually
have actually see the 25th amendment
from a cabinet
who wants to have political careers
post-trump you don't need to do 25th
amendment because
if trump loses on january 20th he's no
longer the president
that's it so i don't think you're going
to need that
kyle says regardless of who wins i would
be lying
to say that i am not ashamed of what's
going on in our country
not the election counting process but
the president and his supporters
who would respect us yeah you know i
didn't
anticipate that this topic would
actually be that interesting
but i found it interesting so yesterday
on the show
i did a story called um the country is
screwed whether trump wins or loses and
it was really
discussing the fact that there's going
to be 70 million trumpists in the
country whether trump wins or loses
and shockingly the clip has 400 000
views and i've gotten more emails about
that clip
than anything we've done recently um
and i think that that's uh i i mean
clearly it's resonating at least with an
important part
of our audience as far as that goes so
um
yeah i i that's i completely agree with
you the shame is not i mean
the votes are being counted there's not
fraud the way don jr and all these
people are suggesting
the embarrassment is that there's 70
million trumpists
in uh in the united states thomas says
david caller from
oh i missed it thomas call her from
paris here sorry for my bad english no
you were perfect
i also wanted to ask do you think biden
can or will try and reform the electoral
college
i don't think he will try and i don't
think he would be able to
i believe the way to reform the
electoral college
most directly is the national popular
interstate
wait npvic national popular vote
interstate compact and i've talked about
that before
and i encourage you to to google it and
and learn a little bit about it
jan schutz says get ready for epic baby
rage from our leader yeah i
i'm i mean so let me know in the chat
is trump going to do anything other than
just alleged fraud
i can't think of anything else trump is
going to do i can't imagine
you know i would be shocked if trump
showed up and said i want to let
everybody know
we must remain calm and let democracy
run its course
we will ultimately know the winner votes
are being counted in the meantime my
focus is coronavirus which i am
committed to
i mean i would be shocked if he did that
and by the way
i would love it if someone raised their
hand and said mr prump
sir you promised a hundred million
vaccine doses
before the election you promised a new
health care plan signed into law
in august you promised to build a wall
across the entire u.s mexico
border you said second coronavirus
stimuli you know like
i would love it if somebody did the sir
routine with him
i don't know if he's going to take
questions you know i
i really don't know but let's get the
latest coronavirus numbers today
yeah 108 000 cases again we had 108
352 yesterday and 108
660 today i they may not even be done
counting for the day
to be totally honest with you uh we we
may
we may even get more which is really
crazy
okay uh joe rader says that falcon 9
just landed that's that's interesting
tony says can we please raid the right
side news stream no we're not going to
do that
i should look at raiding someone though
on twitch just because it's the polite
thing to do
after i'm done streaming i don't know
exactly who it would be
let's see who's streaming that i follow
right now
stephen kenneth destiny banala streaming
grand master hikaru nakamura is
streaming
[Music]
uh botezz live is streaming who else is
streaming that i
follow a bunch of different people yeah
no there's definitely some uh some stuff
ripe
ripe for streaming but first we have to
get through this press
briefing and i can't even imagine what
we are going to see
yeah if you're just joining us we've
been live for a couple of hours but
now is when it's really going to get hot
it's the new hot thing
the way that uh the way the way trump
likes to say
we're expecting to hear from donald
trump any moment do i think georgia is
holding the report of 0.2
or more that gives biden the edge in a
worry of triggering the possible
aftermath
i have no reason to think that but at
the same time i wouldn't put
anything past anybody at this point
because the situation has become
completely wacky
okay now that fox is live we can bail on
the right side broadcasting feed
and we'll be hearing from donald trump i
think very soon
cameras are trained let's get our feed
in hd
i i just have no idea what to expect
here
it's going to be nuts um
jen says she's worried trump is going to
use this time to instigate
fighting between protesting groups
that's my biggest concern i wasn't going
to mention it but because you brought it
up let's discuss it
i'm you know remember stand back and
stand by
i hope this is not a message to those
standing by to stand in
and i think that that's that's all that
needs to be said at this point
but i am i am worried that that is
potentially what we could see here
um samuel says can i get one of those
super alpha two-handed water sips
yeah the the new way i drink water is
like this
trump taught that to me and i like it i
don't know about you guys but i think
it's pretty good
um underscore door says the democratic
flex
blue states in the west have an arm
flexing
and east has the army
bodybuilder dab like pose oh my god i
don't know what you're talking about
um somebody's suggesting i check the
iowa coved numbers let's look at that
where is iowa is it ugly let's take a
look
yeah that's not a good curve that's not
what you want oh oh my
yeah that's a pretty serious spike not
good in iowa but you know
a lot of places are spiking right now
many many places are spiking
update on okay update on memberships
let's see
we're at 125 on the website
from 81 that's 44
which puts us at 234
and then twitch is 2083
which is an additional 40 which puts us
at 274.
nice we've never had a month this solid
on twitch to be perfectly frank
um i love what's up i mean i think
twitch is just a fantastic platform
it's been we we started there last year
it's just been such a great platform
a totally different audience there's a
little overlap with youtube but a
totally different audience
it's been interesting to be on there for
sure trump jr just tweeted saying
daddy should go for total war this is
going to get violent
let me see if i can find the don jr
twitter very quickly don jr twitter
let's see what he tweeted has it been
removed let's see
total war
i'm not seeing anything about total war
best thing oh here it is okay the best
thing for america's future
is for trump to go to total war
oh my god if you're a lunatic proud boy
and you're standing by
and don jr says it's time for total war
that might activate you that might
actually i mean i'm trying to think of
how they would look at that that isn't
that that could be an incitement to
violence per that
is that stochastic terrorism
i don't know but it's monstrous it's
absolutely
monstrous for the the child of a sitting
president
uh to claim it's time to go to total war
unbelievable
yeah i think twitter twitter needs to
delete that i mean it's it's really an
it really is an incitement to violence i
would like to see twitter just delete it
not even flag it um
steve bannon's video got taken down
that's interesting
all available ballots are counted in
north carolina the outstanding absentee
provisional will be reviewed on november
12th when county committees meet that is
state law
okay so we it sounds like we we for that
reason we are getting
nothing else from north carolina for a
week until next thursday
meanwhile the vote count continues in
pennsylvania
new york times has it as a 1.1 vote
margin
ap has it as 1.2 georgia we are still
waiting on
nevada updating once a day so we will
get an update on that count tomorrow
and we are uh standing by for donald
trump
i want to make a note i'm going to send
a note to myself here
um don jr total war
tweet i'm just thinking about what i
want to cover tomorrow
and i don't want to forget that
because that is insane uh don jr talking
about
it's time for total war i mean it's it's
crazy
it's how are we even living through this
let's hope we do live
through it let's maybe that's where we
should stop
yeah we ever you should really report it
that that is a good idea
my 15 year old asked me if we could move
to europe if trump takes the election
told her yes if anyone is taking
americans in 2023
well said will says bill maher always
said this trump is not going to leave
office even if he loses or he is going
to make it difficult what are your
thoughts
yeah i mean i predicted on monday trump
would claim victory in the aftermath of
the election he did i predicted trump
would
uh allege fraud and he did i predicted
trump would start lawsuits and he has
um it's all happening exactly as
predicted
it's all happening exactly as predicted
it looks like they've
maybe gotten the two-minute warning
which is why we have a slow zoom
happening and
people taking pictures of the backdrop i
think we shop
we should be hearing from donald trump
any second
um yeah and it seems everybody is
standing by for donald donald trump at
this point in time so we'll have it very
soon
um and it is going to be wild absolutely
wild i predict
um
okay and are we are we uh keeping up
with banning people appropriately i'm
seeing some
potentially concerning things but uh we
we've actually had a lot of ban hammers
dropped in the last 48 hours it's it
makes me sad
really makes me sad more than anything
else
um okay i'm being told that there was a
delay
but the delay must is was the delay to
now yes it is
all right here we go stand back and
stand by
thank you very much
[Music]
good evening i'd like to provide the
american people with an
update on our efforts to protect the
integrity of our very important 2020
election
if you count the legal votes i
easily win if you count the illegal
votes
they can try to steal commit this man
now
72-hour cycle we're looking at them very
strongly but a lot of
very strong i've already decisively won
many critical states including massive
victories in florida
iowa indiana ohio to name just a few we
won
these and many other victories despite
historic
election interference from big media big
money and big tech
as everybody saw we won by historic
numbers hysteric and the pollsters got
it knowingly wrong the bolsters wrong we
had polls that were so ridiculous
and everybody knew it at the time there
was no blue wave that they predicted
they thought there was going to be a big
blue wave that was remember trump's been
predicting a red wave up until 72 hours
ago
instead there was a big red wave
that's not true properly acknowledged
actually by the media they were
i think very impressed but that was
after the fact that doesn't do us any
good
we kept the senate despite having twice
as many seats to defend as democrats
and in a really much more
competitive states we've uh we did a
fantastic job with the senate i think
we're very proud of what's
happened there in many more seats to
defend they spent almost
200 million dollars on senate races in
south carolina and
right alone two races and
hundreds of millions of dollars overall
against us
at the national level our opponents
major donors were
wall street bankers and special
interests our major donors were police
officers farmers everyday citizens
yet for the first time ever we lost zero
races in the house
i was talking to kevin mccarthy today he
said he couldn't many haven't been
counted yet
very unusual thing zero and actually won
many new seats
with i think many more on the way this
was
also the year of the republican woman
more republican women were elected to
congress than
ever before that's a great achievement i
won the largest share of non-white
voters of any republican in 60 years
including historic
numbers of this is weird it's like did
you win dude
american asian-american and native
american voters
uh the largest ever in our history
we grew our party by four million voters
the greatest turnout
sorry guys i have to interrupt very
powerful raid from grand master hikaru
nakamura
very much appreciate that welcome
everybody very very strong strongest
ever i think
it seems and republicans have become the
party of the american worker and that's
what's happened
and we're also i believe the party of
inclusion
as everyone now recognizes media polling
was
election interference in the truest
sense of polling voters is interfering
with powerful special interests
counting votes is interviews really
phony polls i have to call them phony
polls fake polls were designed to keep
our voters
at home create the illusion of momentum
for mr biden and diminished republicans
ability
notice no more sleepy joe they were
what's called suppression polls has he
ever used the word
mr biden before it's never been used to
the extent that it's been used on this
last election
to highlight just a few examples the day
before election
quinnipiac which was wrong on
love that every occasion that i know
had joe biden up by five points in
florida
and they were off by 8.4 points
and i won florida easily easily
so they had me
losing florida by a lot and i ended up
winning florida by a lot
other than that they were very accurate
they had
him up four points in ohio and they were
off by 12.2 points
and they also won ohio great state of
ohio
very easily beautiful the washington
post said biden up 17 points in
wisconsin
and it was basically even they were off
by about 17 points
and they knew that they're not stupid
people trump lost
suppression there are now only a few
states yet to be
decided in the presidential race the
voting
apparatus of those states are run in all
cases by democrats
we were winning in all the key locations
by a lot
actually and then our numbers started
miraculously getting whittled away
in secret and they wouldn't allow
legally permissible observers we went to
court
in a couple of instances and we were
able to get the observers put in and
when the observers got there they wanted
them
60 70 feet away 80 feet 100 feet away or
outside the building to observe
people inside the building and we won a
case a big case and
we have others happening a lot of lots
of litigation even multiple cases thrown
out all tremendous
amount of litigation generally because
of how unfair this process was and i
predicted that i've been talking about
mail-in voting for we did too it's
it's really destroyed our system it's a
corrupt system
and it makes people corrupt even if they
aren't by nature
but they become corrupt it's too easy
they want to find out how many the votes
they need and then they seem to be able
to find them
they wait and wait and then they find
them and
you see that on election night we were
ahead in vote
in north carolina by a lot tremendous
number of votes
he doesn't seem to understand we're
still ahead by a lot but uh
not as many because they're finding
ballots all of a sudden oh we have
counting it's amazing how those male
and ballots are so one-sided too i know
that it's supposed to be to the
advantage of
the democrats but in all cases they're
so one-sided
we were up by nearly 700 000 votes in
pennsylvania i won pennsylvania by a lot
and that gets whittled down to i think
they said now we're up by 90 000 votes
not even my friends coming and coming
and coming not even them all over
and they don't want us to have any
observers although we want a court case
the judge said you have to have
observers likewise enjoy
and they're appealing actually they're
appealing
we want a case that we want people to
watch and we want observers
and they're actually appealing which is
sort of interesting i wonder why that
appeal
that all we want to do is have people
watch as they do the
vote tabulations tribulations won by a
lot
a lot with a lead of over
getting close to 300 000 votes on
election night
in georgia and by the way got whittled
down
and now it's getting to be to a point
where i'll go from winning by a lot
to perhaps being even down a little bit
yes i'll tell you a pipe burst in a far
away location totally unrelated
to the location of what was happening
and they stopped counting
for four hours isn't this the best a lot
of things happened
a lot of things happening apparatus and
georgia's run by democrats
people snuck fake ballots margins of 300
000 and missions i hate to mute but if
you want to sneak fake ballots in
in atlanta why would you burst the pipe
and stop
counting you would do it quietly without
calling attention to yourself by
bursting a fake pipe
they got whittled down today we're on
track to win
arizona we only need to carry i guess 55
percent
of the remaining vote 55 percent margins
and
that's a margin that we've significantly
exceeded so we'll see what happens with
that but we're on track to do okay in
arizona
our goal is to defend the integrity of
the election we'll not allow
the corruption to steal such an
important election or any election for
that matter
and we can't allow silence anybody to
silence our voters
and manufacture results i've never had
i've been doing
a lot of public things for a long time
i've never had anything that's been
as inspirational by people calling
talking
sending things to us i've never
seen people have sent them things such
love and such affection and such uh
spirit as i've seen for this people know
what's happening and they see what's
happening and it's before their eyes
and there are many instances which will
be reported very shortly
i'd love for him to address losing by
three and a half million votes so
it's a case where they're trying to
steal an election they're trying to rig
an election
and we can't let that happen detroit and
philadelphia known as two of the most
corrupt political places anywhere in our
country
easily behind be responsible for
engineering the outcome of a
presidential race a very important
presidential race
i do worry people will get violent
because of this to the state supreme
court to try and ban
our election observers and very strongly
now we won the case but they're they're
going forward they don't want
anybody in there they don't want anybody
watching them as they
uh count the ballots and
i can't imagine why there's absolutely
no legitimate reason
why they would not want to have people
watching this process because if it's
straight
they would be they should be proud of it
trying obviously to commit fraud
there's no question about that in
philadelphia observers have been
kept far away very far away so far
that people are using binoculars to try
and see and there's been
tremendous problems guys they put um
paper on all of the windows so you can't
see in and the people
that are banned are very unhappy and
become something i saw one guy with a
telescope actually the 11th circuit
ruled
that in georgia the votes have been
in by election day that they should be
in by election day
and they weren't votes are coming in
after election day
and they had a ruling already that you
have to have the votes in by election
day to the best of my knowledge votes
should be in by election day
and they didn't do that democrat
officials never believed they could win
this election honestly i really believe
that
that's why they did the mail-in ballots
where there's tremendous
corruption and fraud going on fraud
that's why they
mailed out tens of millions of
unsolicited ballots without any
verification measures whatsoever
and i've told everybody that uh these
things would happen
because i've seen it happen i watched a
lot of different elections
has he said anything true so far decided
to go with this big massive
election with tens of millions about i
guess every state he's mentioned
is a state in many cases totally
unsolicited
this was unprecedented in american
history this was by design despite years
of
claiming to care about the election
security
they refused to include any requirement
to verify signatures
identities or even determine whether
they're eligible or
ineligible to vote people are walking in
there they have no idea
they're just taking wow the numbers
they're writing down things the workers
and doing a lot of bad things and we
have a lot of
information coming and litigation that
you'll see that will
shake even your people up and you've
seen it all the officials
one point in pennsylvania pennsylvania
and other key states
one point a corrupt democrat machine
that you've written about and
for a long time you've been writing
about the corrupt democrat machine
i went to school there and i know a lot
about it hasn't changed
a long time ago and hasn't changed it's
gotten worse
in pennsylvania partisan democrats have
allowed ballots in the state to be
received three days after the election
and we think much more than that and
they are counting those
without even postmarks or any
identification
whatsoever so you don't have postmarks
you don't have identification
there have been a number of disturbing
irregularities across the
nation are tough readings denied access
to observe
any counting in detroit detroit is
another place
and uh i wouldn't say has the best
reputation for
election integrity poll workers in
michigan were duplicating ballots
but when our observers attempted to
challenge the activity those poll
workers jumped
in front of the volunteers to block
their views so that they couldn't see
what they were doing
papers and binoculars a little bit
dangerous
one major hub for counting ballots in
detroit covered up the windows again
with large pieces of cardboard and
so they wanted to it was construction
paper accounting area they didn't want
anybody seeing the county even though
these were observers who were
legal observers that were supposed to be
there in detroit there were hours of
unexplained delay in delivering many of
the votes for counting
the final batch should not arrive until
four in the morning did you see that
and uh even though the polls closed at
eight o'clock so they brought it in
and the batches came in and nobody knew
where they came from
we've also been denied access to observe
in critical places in georgia
and multiple swing states counting was
halted for hours
and hours on election night with results
withheld from
major democrat-run locations only to
appear
later and they certainly appeared and
they all had the name biden on them were
just about all
i think almost all wow georgia down to
0.1 just a little strange
0.1 in georgia oh my god democrat to
clarify that they only want legal votes
because they talk about votes and i
think they should use the word legal
legal vote seeing his leads shrink
as he talks is just amazing every legal
vote counted we want
openness and transparency no secret
count rooms
no mystery ballots no illegal votes
being cast after election day you have
election day and the laws are very
strong on that you have an election day
and they have elections votes cast after
election day and
they want the process to be an honest
one it's so important we want an honest
election
we want an honest count and we want
honest people working
back there because it's a very important
job so that's the way
this country is going to win that's the
way the united how about those 100
million vaccine doses
the election very easily we think
there's going to be a lot of litigation
because we have so much evidence so much
proof and
it's going to end up perhaps at the
highest court in the land
we'll see but we think there'll be a lot
of litigation because we can't have
an election stolen like this and i i
tell you i was
i have been talking about this for many
months with all of you
and i've said very strongly that mail-in
ballots are going to end up being a
disaster
small elections were a disaster small
very easy to handle elections
were disastrous uh this is a large-scale
version
will he take questions guys do you think
we're hearing stories that are horror
stories absolute horror stories
and we can't let that happen to the
united states of america it's not a
question of who wins
republican democrat joe myself
we can't let that happen to our country
we can't be disgraced by having
something like this happen
so it will be thank you very much
everybody maybe soon i hope soon
but it'll probably go through a process
a legal process and
as you know i've claimed certain states
and uh he's claiming states so we can
both claim the states
biden's not claiming any states that
media is not giving him
but there's been a lot of shenanigans in
blaming the state stand for that in our
country
thank you very much there it is
wow what a pathetic joke guys what a
pathetic
joke so basically trump's the biggest
victim in the world
everything's being taken from him
there's cardboard
uh there's cardboard on windows
and he would have already won everything
were it not for the media
do i is that more or less it like do i
more or less have it
is that generally speaking what he said
i think i've gotten everything now by
the way
very very interesting updates as donald
trump was talking
the pennsylvania numbers got even closer
where they went from a 1.2 percent
margin to 1.1
and per the associated press
pennsylvania is now a 1.0 margin just 63
no 64 300 64 000
261
something like that separating the two
candidates that's very very interesting
and then going over to georgia georgia
now as close as it has been
down to one tenth of a point only
36 35
30 am i right on that 3635 votes
now separating donald trump and joe
biden
in georgia a per the associated press
on georgia they are also at the exact
same thing
36 35 were all square and even
as far as that goes uh 34 35 people
saying very good okay
i'm never i never claim i said my math
would be quick but i never said it would
be correct
and then in the meantime arizona has
tightened a little bit
arizona has tightened to a 2.2
percentage point margin but
a lot of things happening i'm not going
to say quickly
but things are certainly certainly
happening um okay that is going to end
my coverage today if you are watching
over
on twitch i do want to invite you let's
rate it let's rate a small
uh let hold on let's see here let's rate
a small channel
and see if it's somebody who might enjoy
who do we have that small
channels that i follow over on oh you
know what
let's raid the chess bras
um can i do that yeah let's do it i
think that they will be very very
surprised because i have uh
um i don't even think that they know
this this is fun i love rating a small
channel so let's do it
everybody on youtube make sure to hit
the subscribe button so when we go live
tomorrow with what hopefully will be
something decisive
um you will be notified alright thanks
everybody see you soon